you remember when i filled my house with
those plastic play balls sure i fronted
40 grand for them balls and at that time
it was so hard for me to do
and i remember freaking out like how do
i pay these balls off like i need to
capitalize on these balls so i did the
same thing i'll sign
everybody that places an order i'll sign
a ball wow and it was like
instantly sixty thousand dollars like we
paid the balls off instantly everybody
got a ball sign it was just like such a
fun story of like how well that
signature worked yeah and how quickly it
was like instant dancing yeah i mean
were you broke at the time or i wasn't
broke but
i mean
roman's been killing it for a long time
yeah but that that video single-handedly
changed my whole career so it was before
that um i certainly had the income to
pay it but coming from broke i was
always so scared to spend
40k for a wing i have no idea if this is
going to be a hit right it's like a risk
i think that as a rule
if you for me
like if i'm
investing because that's all i do you
know it's like uh it's like oh man you
know like i'm gonna do a podcast let me
buy a crazy expensive sprinter van yeah
best purchase i ever made yeah and then
it's like oh i'm on tour now i've
graduated to theaters like renting a
tour bus sucks let me buy a piece of
[ __ ] rv best move i ever made you know
like and
and and production wise like i've spent
insane amounts of money to to produce
like you know big stuff and every time
i've bet on myself in that regard it's
it's worked out yeah i think any time
that you invest putting money back into
your career so that you can give
better quality
like content like uh
like stuff like then it's always a good
fit make your money make money i was
reading this stat today the like the two
most sexiest things a man can do is
one have like veins popping out of his
arms and yeah it was like it was like
really attractive for women to see veins
and then another one is being a
successful risk taker like risking it
and then like being successful
thank god he prioritized veins first
it's just those two things it's pretty
wide range
and also you hit a point where
especially in our field you've got to
have tax write-offs right we have so
little overhead on youtube
you have to my account when i really
started making money it was
actually it was absurd
he would he would literally call me like
you have to spend
this much money this week or you're
giving it to the government so it would
just force us to blow money it was like
we would just buy everything we need was
a new work truck
a skid steer for the property we just
blow money
and it's like these type of things those
are expenses that you write off help
avoid taxes they're all business expense
they grow your company i don't think i
have any trouble whatsoever uh spending
money the because i mean like
we put money into production and that's
you know
like i i you'll see tonight and by the
way i'm so excited that you're coming to
my show so yeah like so pumped we
i'm [ __ ] flying around all over
on a helicopter dangling from a rope
this is big then yeah because you know
where the last time i saw your show was
yeah it was a big bar it was nice yeah
it was it was a comedy club yeah nice
club but it sounds like you're i mean
this is something i filmed for like uh
but my show now is multimedia so in the
opening sequence i'm like [ __ ] on the
roof of the house and this helicopter
drops a rope bladder and i grab it i'm
flying around like crashing through all
this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] helicopter flies over this
tour bus and i'd drop off the rope
ladder and land on the roof of the
moving tour bus oh my god and then it's
like the tour bus like takes me to the
theater and and that's how it gets so
yeah the last show you were at was the
ice house pasadena i think it might be
it might be and then we all went out
after yeah it might be
yeah i mean whatever it's great we've
known each other for a good amount of
time and i'm excited to to really get
into how much you changed my life
on your podcast i think that clip was
awesome but not as awesome as my new
book a hard kick in the nuts what i've
learned from a lifetime of terrible
decisions which is out september 27th
and if you pre-order it right now you
can get the autographed copy so get on
it man pre-order my book it's not going
to waste your time because i'm proven
dude new york times bestseller
my first book's five star rated on
amazon and i have no doubt this one will
be two so get the autographed copy right
now by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
dude